je
con k ox can hold sabéis qué significa
esto estoy contando en maya al igual que
otras civilizaciones los mayas también
desarrollaron un sistema de numeración
como era te invita que viajemos en el
tiempo para descubrir los fascinantes
números mayas y encontrar las
diferencias y similitudes con nuestro
sistema decimal primero es importante
que sepas que este sistema tiene una
base vigesimal o por decirlo de una
manera más fácil se basa en agrupaciones
de 20 sólo tenían tres símbolos que se
combinaban según el número que se quería
representar y estos eran el punto que su
valor es uno una raya con valor de cinco
y el caracol concha o semilla con valor
de cero
estos tres símbolos combinados daban
como resultado la siguiente numeración
te voy a dar la primera diferencia que
encontramos nuestro sistema decimal
tiene base 10 o sea 10 símbolos pero
comparte una similitud con el sistema
maya los símbolos se pueden combinar
dependiendo del número que se quiere
representar otro punto que debes de
saber es que tanto el sistema maya como
el decimal son sistemas de numeración
posicional es qué quiere decir esto
quiere decir que el valor de cada
símbolo depende de su posición dentro de
la cifra por ejemplo no es lo mismo si
escribo 1976 a que si escribo 6 791 en
nuestro sistema decimal la posición del
número es horizontal es decir va de
izquierda a derecha
si tenemos 1976 el 1 vale más que el 9
el 9 vale más que el 7
el 7 más que el 6 debido a que cada uno
ocupa una posición más alta que el
siguiente
nosotros nos acomodamos en unidades de
millar centenas de escenas y unidades
en este caso el 1 representa el 1000 el
9 representa a 900 el 770 y el 61 un
ejemplo más si tenemos un 2 y un 8 en el
sistema decimal como sabemos qué
cantidad representa
pues bien el 2 corresponde a la posición
de decenas y se multiplica por 10 y el 8
corresponde a la de unidades y se
multiplica por 1
entonces 20 8 nos da 28
en el sistema de numeración maya ocurre
algo parecido pero en lugar de acomodar
los símbolos en unidades de millar
centenas de escenas y unidades lo hacen
por niveles empiezan de abajo hacia
arriba y no multiplican el símbolo por
10 sino por 20 recuerda que es un
sistema vigesimal o sea de base de 20 es
sencillo en el primer nivel el símbolo
se multiplica por 1 en el segundo nivel
por 20 en el tercero por 400 que es lo
mismo que 20 por 20
en el cuarto por 8000 o sea 20 x 20 x 20
y así sucesivamente cada vez que aumenta
un nivel se multiplica una vez más por
20 y no te espantes veamos un ejemplo si
queremos representar el 28 como lo
haremos recuerda que solo tenemos estos
tres símbolos el caracol que 0 el punto
que es 1 y la raya que es 5
para el 8 escribimos una raya que
equivale a 5 y 3 puntos arriba de ella
uno más uno más uno es igual a tres
entonces 53 nos da 8
listo así representamos el 8 en el nivel
1 8 por 1 es igual a 8
y el 20 saca lápiz y papel pausa el
vídeo y piensa cómo representar y hasta
el 20 es muy fácil
listo para el 28 lo único que tenemos
que hacer es dibujar un punto en el
segundo nivel porque un punto porque en
el segundo nivel el valor del símbolo se
multiplica por 20 1 por 20 nos da 20 y
20 más 8 del primer nivel obtenemos 28
perfecto como te diste cuenta el nivel
de menor valor es el primero y aumenta
hacia arriba ahora que ya sabes esto
ayuda a identificar los siguientes
números mayas si en el nivel 1 tenemos
un punto en el nivel 2 3 puntos y en el
nivel 3 una raya que número es en el
primer nivel
el punto representa 1 1
para el segundo nivel tenemos tres
puntos que multiplicamos por 20 y nos da
para el tercer nivel encontramos una
raya que vale 5 recuerda que este nivel
se multiplica 20 por 20 o sea 400
entonces 5 por 400 es igual a 2000
esto quiere decir que el número
representado es 2 mil 61
un ejemplo más tenemos una raya en el
primer nivel tres rayas en el segundo y
por último dos rayas en el tercero qué
número tenemos hagamos lo mismo que en
el ejemplo anterior la raya del primer
nivel equivale a cinco pues cinco por
uno es igual a cinco en el segundo nivel
las tres rayas equivalen la 15 porque
cada una de ellas vale 5 y si
multiplicamos 15 por 20 obtenemos 300
en el tercer nivel las dos rayas
equivalen a 10 y esto x 400 nos da 4000
entonces cuatro mil más 300 más 5
tenemos cuatro mil 305 wow
qué divertido es un dato importante es
que los mayas usaron todo esto no solo
para hacer cálculos sino también para
medir el tiempo no dejes de maravillarse
con los números mayas sigue conociendo
los y practicando con ellos